so this article this story comes out
yesterday and everyone's talking about a
forecast for U.S recession within a year
hits 100 in blow to Biden and Bloomberg
is part of his camp that they went out
of their way trying to help fight and
win elections so this is not a good look
when you're seeing a number like this
Bloomberg economic sees near uh
certainty downtown will start tightening
conditions inflation hawkish fed way on
Outlook 100 so if you can zoom in here
to see what kind of numbers they have uh
the latest recession probability models
by Bloom Economist Anna Wong and Elisa
Winger forecast a higher recession
probability across all time frames with
the 12-month estimate of a downturn by
October 2023 hitting 100 up from 65 from
the for the comparable period in the
previous update do they have any reasons
how they came up with this model
Bloomberg surveys 40 42 economists
predicts the probability next to 150
earlier I mean the numbers just don't
look good no matter where you look at
the numbers don't look good uh you're
you're now finally hearing
realtors in Texas is lower meaning
people are leaving the industry mortgage
is getting hit hardcore rates are going
to continue to go up Powell's saying
they're going to keep increasing rates
till they hit two percent inflation uh
next year you're gonna feel the
unemployment happening in 2023 my
prediction is with that part but I think
recession will be full on recession my
opinion is uh November 8th Wednesday of
this year okay is it November 8th or
November 9th what is November 7th is
midterm election yes eighth is the
election eighth is the election is going
to be November 9th Wednesday this one
they can announce recession till then
we're not in recession right now
according to the experts in the U.S
government right is they're just gonna
they're gonna change the definition
again it doesn't matter how many times
we hit we're already in a recession but
they're just going to change the
definition they're going to go to
Webster's and have Webster's reprint all
new dictionaries
this is not a good look though did you
see the Gallup poll that came out did
you did you see the gallopol that came
out about uh uh uh gallup's been doing
this pull for the last eight years since
1940 okay and the whole poll is about a
better job handling problem you think
most important who Republicans Or
democrats do you trust can do do can do
a better job handling problems today and
this is Gallup the same Fox the same CNN
okay
48 said Republicans 37 percent said
Democrats today and here's the crazy
thing about this data since 1940 when
they started doing this poll
the widest margin they've ever had was
17 points in 1946
Truman was President this is right after
new you know 1945 1946 the American
people went towards Republicans over
Democrats 11 is the second largest since
1946 the highest since 1946 and again
the same facts this is not New York Post
this is not Breitbart this is not Siena
this is not MSNBC this is Gallup so the
American people are sitting there saying
listen Biden I'm sure your family loves
you but we kind of are due for a
different leader to run this country so
what are your thoughts down when you
hear this Bloomberg saying 100
um I would say there's also 100 chance
that Michael Bloomberg is running for
president in 24 and he's basically you
know gonna let these kind of stories go
out and kind of help clear the decks and
he's sitting back there with I can see
Michael Bloomberg sitting there at the
scotch 61 flips I'm gonna make sure
there's 80. and then I'm running in 24
baby you really think he's running well
I mean you could connect the dots I'm
being kind of cynical and funny but I'm
connecting the dots but I'll go back to
something I said several podcasts ago
remember I said that I thought that you
know liberal media were kind of keeping
themselves on a leash but they were
slowly rolling now on on Biden and
they're just waiting for when the DNC
because it's exactly the process you
talked about for you know for individual
candidates for Congress that there's
also a date that when the DNC has the
Thunder money available to the National
presidential candidates and there'll
only be about four or six of them to get
access to that money and you know
Governor California desperately wants to
be put on the short list so we can get
access to it and I just think that what
what's happening with the media is some
of the liberal media is coming clean and
there's and they're truthfully reporting
things that are out there and it's not
favorable to the president but the
gloves are off and they were trying to
hold back a little bit help the
president but I think the gloves are off
in the form of hey we're just going to
say what it is and I the reason you can
say it's 100 chance for a recession is
because I believe I think you believe
we're already there yeah take a look at
here look look at what's happened in
these home things so
Realtors have jobs I don't think so the
people are in loan origination of jobs I
don't think so I think there's a whole
section of financial services industry
that's unemployed or underemployed right
now so when you take a look at all that
you're telling me that we're not already
in
the original accepted definition of a
recession right now and I think their
media is just coming out and saying it
they're coming out and saying it first
Obama says listen this woke stuff's not
working then Bloomberg says all in the
same week do you think there was a
meeting saying guys it's time for us the
voices of the democratic party to say
we're not with what Biden's doing so
they can come out and start their
endorsement this weekend next week so
some of the people that they're
endorsing their voice has way to say we
don't support the walk decisions that's
been happening the last 24 months or 18
months we need to go back to what Dems
used to do the timing of what Bloomberg
said Obama said all at the same time
it's kind of weird to me I I agree with
that I agree with you do you think
Obama's got friends that are in Risky
seats right now how
ugly things going to be on on midterms
GOP is going to win the house they're
not going to win the Senate and so
that's how it's going to play out by my
assessment
and I think when they win the house
they're gonna pull some military
generals up the house will because
they'll have the ability to hold
committees and call some people make
some headlines But ultimately in terms
of legislation you know you still got
the president that can veto Senate will
still be a slim majority if not almost a
coin toss when you add you know people
that can vote against the party
and so really we're gonna have two years
where it's really going to come down to
the 24 election and so that's my
assessment of it I you know you look at
races like Herschel Walker in Georgia
where I think a lot of people thought he
was going to win I'm not convinced he's
going to win I don't think Oz has a
great chance in Pennsylvania either I
think that's another sentence weird one
I know it is a weird one what is that's
a very weird candidate uh so people want
authenticity right now so look at the
Democrat he's like this Philly guy with
this big goatee and then you got this
dorky white boy Dr Oz I mean just on the
surface without get like a deeper look
at you know their policies I can see why
people especially from the Pennsylvania
area would be veering toward
authenticity
um and then you know the Ohio race is
much tighter than we thought it would be
and then the New Hampshire race is one
where the Republicans are trying to
steal one
um and we'll see so those are really the
four key races in the senate in
I guess we'll see how it plays out
ultimately I think what you're saying is
candidates matter meaning like 100 you
know Herschel Walker you thought that
you know and he'd have a chance but
Rafael Warnock looks he's gonna win the
same same as oz so if you use just
generic polling Like Pat referenced
generic uh Republicans have a quite an
advantage I think it went from three to
ten percent on Independence and that's
on a New York Times poll so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]